At first glance, The Hogeweyk looks a lot
like any other neighborhood in the Netherlands.
It’s got a restaurant, barber shop, theater,
grocery store, and open green space.
You can see people walking around, getting
groceries, having coffee.
The difference is that this neighborhood is
a facility for people with severe dementia.
And everyone else in it
from grocery store cashiers to barbers
to waiters
are trained in dementia care.
This model of care has been dubbed
a "dementia village".
As people continue to live longer
around the world,
the proportion of older people in the population
will continue to rise
and that means a steep increase in
the number of people with dementia.
Caring for that population will require
designing environments
that help people feel safe and free
even as they lose the ability to recognize
the world around them.
And the architects behind dementia villages
think they might just have figured out
the formula to do it.
This is The Hogeweyk.
Social life is happening there
so you can see it now.
That's Eloy van Hal, one of
The Hogeweyk's founders.
Dementia, it's — of course — a brain disease.
If you look at your life as a photo album
you forget the last pictures.
The last pictures, they fall out of the album
and so you remember the past better
when you were younger.
And that's a daily challenge for the individuals:
how to live with memory loss.
In early stages, people with dementia can
live at home, looked after by family, friends
or home care
but they eventually need full-time care.
Often, that care comes from traditional
nursing homes.
But those settings can be sterile and clinical.
You all dine together in a big dining area.
You all have to listen to the same music
at the same time.
Where you're forced as a person into a program
of the institution.
There's not that much attention to
who are you really
what is my life's story, who am I,
what do I prefer
to do during the whole day.
In any setting, the goal
of good dementia care
should be to preserve quality of life
as dementia progresses.
In traditional settings, like nursing homes
surface-level changes are
a good place to start.
Since people with dementia might perceive
dark tiles as holes
floors should be visually consistent,
without contrasting patterns.
Brightly colored doors and handrails help
residents navigate around
and bright dishware has been shown to help
people with Alzheimer’s eat more food.
Acoustic ceiling tiles, carpeted floors,
and soft furniture
can absorb noises that trigger disorientation.
Glass-fronted cabinets help residents have
a clear line of sight
to what’s stored inside.
And lighting fixtures that mimic natural light
strengthen residents’ circadian rhythms,
which helps mitigate sundowning
where people with dementia become confused
in the evening and night.
Some of the advice about lighting, clear lines,
surface patterns, and so
are based on institutions.
Instead of normalizing the environments, all
those elements are essential.
But sometimes they are the solution
for an institution.
But The Hogeweyk’s design solution is different.
Instead of changing surface-level design to
preserve quality of life for people with dementia
they took a structural approach
and designed their facility to look as much
like the outside world as possible.
Our guiding principle here is normalcy.
It’s the vision of a normal life for people
living with dementia.
That starts with lodging.
Traditional nursing homes keep all their residents
under one roof.
But real households don’t typically consist
of dozens of people.
So, The Hogeweyk split its residents up
into small groups of 6 or 7
recreating the scale of a single family home.
Inside, each resident has a private room
furnished with personal belongings.
The units are split up into different neighborhoods
to mimic Dutch cities residents are used to.
The public space, the gardens, the streets,
the squares.
They are equally important if you want to
build a community where people live.
Each neighborhood’s public space was given
distinct landscapes and unique landmarks
so people could easily find their way around.
And destinations like the theater, barber
shop, and grocery store
were put in separate buildings
encouraging intentional movement and intermingling
in that public space.
These different areas provide multiple scales
of experience
and residents are given the autonomy to safely
wander along that spectrum
from very private to very public space.
That autonomy helps further preserve
quality of life.
People stay in their own bedroom.
Many people socialize in the living room.
But you can also decide to leave the house
because the front door is open and to walk
to your own private outdoor space
your terrace or balcony or your own garden
or you walk further into the neighborhood
where you can mingle.
So, it's about choice, choice, choice:
where you want to be during the whole day
and with whom.
Crucially, The Hogeweyk’s design allows
for
a balance of safe design and controlled risk.
Walkways, for example, don't have
super high walls
to guarantee no one falls over.
You see handrails everywhere in institutions.
The question is, do you need a handrail everywhere?
Or do you want to provide a walker, where
you can walk with two hands on the walker,
and make it accessible for the walker?
Since The Hogeweyk opened in 2009
dozens of other dementia villages have
opened across the globe.
But without ample government funding,
they can be prohibitively expensive.
And there isn’t enough evidence yet to say
whether the dementia village model is better
than traditional models of care.
The Hogeweyk claims that since they transitioned
from a traditional model to the village
the number of residents on antipsychotic medication
decreased from 50 percent in 1993
to just 8-10 percent today.
And there have been studies backing up different
features that dementia villages use.
One review of the evidence found that
uncrowded, small-scale living
resulted in fewer psychiatric symptoms and
behavioral issues among residents with dementia.
And that increased daylight lighting reduced
their behavioral issues
and improved spatial orientation.
Another review found that outdoor gardens
can reduce agitation
and improve quality of life
for people with dementia.
But by creating an environment specifically
for people with cognitive and physical impairments
dementia villages are a fascinating practice
in universal design:
design that works for as many people as possible,
regardless of their ability.
And they can teach us something about where
the outside world falls short.
If you design well for normal people
without dementia
you design also well for people with dementia.
We forgot that people with dementia
are human beings
with a lot of aspirations.
We forgot that people with dementia
are not patients
where you can put them in a chair
and wait until they die.
They are people who want to do certain things
during the day.
And they know and they're happy
to have this freedom.